you decide so let's talk about our next
console for us the console is vital and
central to our experience we heard you a
console should be designed and built and
optimized for one thing and one thing
only gaming so the same team that
created the world's most powerful
console Xbox one X and innovated its
groundbreaking processor and the elite
controller the same team that engineered
the world-class compatibility of today's
Xbox one consoles the same team that set
the bar for live gaming services with
Xbox Live this same team set out on a
new mission to create the future of
gaming for you when we think about the
future of gaming it's not just PC it's
not just console it's not just mobile
it's really all of the above Xbox is all
about choice we're investing in
technology all throughout the game stack
the games you want with the people you
want on the devices that you want and
for us that starts with our
next-generation console
we don't want to build just another
console we truly want it to be
transformative more immersion more
exploration more detail how do we make
it easier for people to get into they
came to stay in the game one of the
things that gamers and developers are
incredibly excited about is reducing
load times I'm an RPG gamer and so like
loading screens are a thing sitting
there in the fake elevator because you
know that the games loading in the
background there's just an elevator ride
forever
that's our goal with gaming is that you
don't have those pauses this generation
is going to be a bigger leap than any
generation we've done before at the
heart of our next-generation console is
our custom design processor leveraging
the latest Xen - and Navi technology
from our partners at AMD from a pure
processing perspective this is four
times more powerful than the Xbox one X
we're leveraging high bandwidth GDD our
six to ensure that we're getting the
best performance possible it's gonna
occur in resolution and frame rates that
we've never seen before like never seen
before we're looking at frame rates up
to 120 frames per second 8k capability
variable refresh rate next-gen ray
tracing it's real-time because it's
hardware accelerated for the first time
ever what I'm personally most excited
about is the SSD
we've created a new generation of SSDs
we're actually using the SSD as virtual
ram we're seeing more than 40 times
performance increases over the current
generation the combination of the SSD
and the solid state drive are really
what gives you a totally new experience
now we can take all of that power and
apply it back into the scene so we can
actually generate more life in that
world and bring it to the game or in a
seamless way so that then you're fully
experiencing what the game developer
wants you to experience when you can
move through worlds without waiting for
screens to low that speed that
performance is what the next generation
is about this is the most immersive
console experience ever
what we really want to do is give
developers the power to build the game
they've always envisioned we have
hundreds of people across both of our
first party studios as well as our third
party studios working on those next
generation experiences today it's an
amazing commitment to content at Xbox
game studios 13 studios seven in the
last year that's a big family at 343 for
us it's always about more seamless
worlds with the next generation we can
bring the world to life in a way we've
never experienced halo before we're
delivering four generations of content
better than you've ever seen them before
this console is especially awesome for
game Pass members with the faster load
times you're going to be able to
experience all the games within just
snap of your fingers we are giving
gamers the option to connect across
devices and across platforms in a way
that we never were able to before this
isn't just a console launch this is
about the future of gaming your games
your achievements your progression your
accessories your console gaming
experience with Xbox it all comes
forward a scarlet
[Music]
it eats monsters for breakfast this is
project starlight the most powerful and
highest performing console we've ever
designed built for creators to unleash
their boldest creative visions and
optimize for players to enjoy the
ultimate gaming experience on a console
anywhere immersive experiences begin at
the very heart of the console at the
silicon level itself together with our
partners at AMD we have Co engineered
and custom design a state of the art
processor for project Scarlett
power you could see defined previous
generations power and performance you
can see and feel defines project scarlet
when we talk about freedom to play when
we talk about Xbox in the cloud when we
talk about streaming your games project
scarlet and all of its power and all of
its performance is the foundation of our
future and console and the formation of
our future in cloud we launched Xbox 18
years ago with the game reviewers called
the definitive reason to own an Xbox
well because humanity was and is worth
saving next holiday we will launch
project scarlet with Halo
[Applause]